and I really worry about the concept of
God I really worry about it I worry
about the work that it does I worry
about the way that it still seems to
establish humans as Superior to every
other species I worry about the way that
it still seems to establish men as more
important than women and like gendered
others
um I worry about the way that because of
Europe's traditional
um alignment with that particular
monotheistic God it tends to establish
the supremacy of Europe and by extension
America over every other region of the
world
um so I worry that if we don't do work
on that concept of God we just leave it
there intact as grounding all of these
hierarchies and then we can say oh but
it doesn't exist right that God doesn't
exist but that doesn't get rid of all of
those conceptual
adherences that keep those uh dualities
and those hierarchies in place I think
there's something to be said for like
working on the concept itself to say you
know what Divinity does not mean
omnipotence